foreign
carried by the breeze in the griesdale
forest in the north of England
as I drifted between the trees
surrounded by the chatter of the forest
swirling waves of pink and purpling off
me
plumes of carbon dioxide and oxygen as
the forest breed
mesmerized by the beauty never before
glimpsed by human eyes and I was in ore
then I was eaten by a dragonfly
I became a dragonfly and discovered a
magical world in which the entire Forest
unfurled like a film in slow motion yet
faster than your iPhone camera could
capture it
through my dragonfly eyes I took in my
surroundings with pretty much a full
spectrum of light
unlike my human self had ever been able
to perceive
these forays into becoming something
other than human came about as part of
our experiential art piece called in the
eyes of the animal which I developed
with my creative Partners Barney and
Robin alongside the members of our Art
Collective marshmallow laser feast
our aim was to translate the sensory
perception of different species a
mosquito a dragonfly a frog and an owl
so we can more deeply understand how
they see hear and feel
it was for us a step into um melts a
concept coined by the pioneering
biologist Jacob wonixko to describe the
unique sensor world of an organism
human notion of reality is just one
among Millions each species has its own
extraordinary and unknowable experience
of reality based on the unique ways
their senses translate the world around
them
in essence
your and my own wealth fundamental
differs from the unwell to the mosquito
or a dragonfly
Marcel pruz once wrote the only true
Voyage of Discovery is to behold the
universe Through The Eyes of another our
Voyage of Discovery into Animal Kingdom
led us to plant kingdom and eventual to
trees where Miracles appear in every
level of magnification all we need to do
is to look closely in 2016 we found
ourselves standing in front of a giant
psychiatry in Sequoia National Park in
California
these giant trees are portals through
which you leave your human
self-importance behind and embody
something much larger much stranger much
more than human
all I could think of was
what is it like to be a tree
what is it like to be one of the largest
organisms that has ever existed
one that has endured more than 2 500
years
how does it feel to host a vast verb of
relationships that anchor an entire
ecosystem
now step with me into this giant as we
appear through the park the vascular
system of the tree reveals itself
infinitely complex patterns and
relationships connects all forms of life
into a tapestry of interdependence
carbon and water more than a thousand
liters of water in fact flow freely
through the phloem and xylem tubes carry
it along we Ascend to the canopy among
the neon green moss and the Lichen
covered branches we shrink in size and
sit upon a pine needles a photon of
light hits the surface water turns into
oxygen and the life we know it
materializes in front of us
this extraordinary journey of water
inspired us to create our multi-sensory
mixed reality installation called
trihager
with a team of scientists programmers
Engineers lidar scanners and scent
makers we immerse ourselves in the inner
workings of a sequoia to render visible
what was otherwise invisible to human
eyes
Miley Swanson composer and the musician
recorded human and plant bioelectrical
signals
to give us a symphony a soundscape
composed in collaboration with the Flora
in fact that's what you've been hearing
all along
participants wore a haptic West
feel these vibrations as if they are on
heartbeat
bringing us a step closer imagining what
it is like to be a tree
when we contemplate the relationship
between our breeding cells and the
breeding planet we encounter this great
question
why does my body end
and where does the world begin
as you ask yourself this question
I'd like you to pay attention to your
breath
inhale slowly
and exhale
feel your tree-like lungs filling and
emptying with a rhythmic flow of Ash
oxygenated blood reaches your hearts
your heart pumps like murmuration of
birds feeding rivers from the center
outwards to touch every cell in your
body
under your skin you realize you are much
like a forest ecosystem
in modern industrial societies we tend
to limit our being to our body
shaped by the confines of your skin your
body is you and that's where your you
ends
yet
when we Trace our out breath the
boundary between inside and outside
between self and other blurs the air we
breathe transcends boundaries sustaining
life as it flows between all beings
we take anywhere from seventeen thousand
to thirty thousand breads a day
third of those breads coming from the
forests and the rest coming from the
oceans
this puts us in an intimate relationship
with the trees thousands of times a day
you might think you've never met a giant
sequoia before but in fact you've been
enmeshed and entangled with one every
moment you've been alive
in other words
we are as much trees as trees are us
our multi-sensory mixed reality
installation called we live in an ocean
of air started with this realization
by translating the um melt of trees for
human understanding it underscores the
bond between humans and The Wider family
of life through respiration
as participants follow their outfit into
a tree they become one
now
notice your out Breath Again
carbon dioxide that leaves your body
lands on a leaf
opens it pores to drink it in
carbon travels through the phloem into
the branches
down the tree trunk and even all the way
down to the soil
here
trees are in ancient cooperation with
the kingdom of fungi
These Fine threads of mycelium those
intelligent root-like fungal networks
that nurture and feed an entire
ecosystem
by simply Tracing Our out breath we
realize the reciprocity between all
major kingdoms of Life pulsing with one
harmonious rhythm
this exploration of rich and diverse
life that exists beneath the surface of
the soil is the next Journey we are
embarking on
as fungi captured a public imagination
through groundbreaking research we are
very much inspired by The Works of Susan
smart Merlin sheldrake and many others
the World Wide Web which is the working
title will bring us into the primordial
relationship between trees plants
animals and fungi and aim to dismantle
the myth of human separation from the
natural world
is an artist's Collective we seek to
find emotional resonance in scientific
stories
stories that connects us to the more
than human world
and coupled with emerging Technologies
deepen our understanding of what is it
to be something other than human
modern science is revealing something
indigenous knowledge has always helped
to be true that what is outside of us is
not separate from us
we need this ancient wisdom more than
ever today and it compels us to use our
technology to both honor and enhance our
relationship with the web of beings
the ability to perceive the world
through the eyes and ears of other
beings
through the phloem and xylem of trees
even reconnects us humans to the
fantastic and richly diverse network of
organisms that make up our shared Earth
it gives us a greater appreciation of
what is it to be non-human which in turn
lets us more fully grasp what is it to
be human too
and it reminds us with or that we are
all but extensions of one another from
three to three to you and me thank you
foreign